[Music]
I spent the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky my dad
this is built on their shoulders
hey mama can I help you let me get a
autograph no I ain't sounding an
autographs but you get off my car you
all remember me huh
foreign
[Music]
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
she's got out last week
because now you back up I know I've been
away a long time but kept myself in
shape I still got gas in the tank how
about a gym
thank you
[Music]
guys what happened with you too oh you
can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
you don't always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I bounce for you you
think you mad trying to spending half
your life in the cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something that's going on with you
I mean was like family
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
that God whatever was and walk into what
is I feel those chains are breaking yeah
foreign
[Music]